i'm on a mission to road test some of
the best celebrity chef cookery courses
on offer to you
fish fanatic alba zilli is my next
target the cheeky little bastard said
maybe one day i'd learn how to cook
properly well now he's got his chance to
teach me so i'm going undercover to road
test his cookery course to have a bit of
fun and to see what get away with
zilli's course costs 352 pounds and on
it you learn how to make stock different
types of pasta and how to prepare and
cook fish
trying to come and sit up here sir
can that gentleman come up here
i can't wait to learn some nice things
today
to get on this course for beginners i've
told him on a novice but will he notice
that there's really an award-winning
chef in his kitchen
time for a bit of fun and the odd clue
what you don't want to do with stocks is
you don't want to
mix too many colors into the stock too
many color vegetables the stock's
overheating so i take the matter in hand
will he twig
hands on
he's listening
mr deli i think it's ready now
i think it's ready
okay put the tomato sauce in if it's
ready he's impressed but oblivious
brilliant
next up zilli's showing us how he makes
pasta now it's our turn finally i'm on a
course where i get to make something see
this is when you've added too much flour
too quickly
okay so it's really hard
so he thinks it's crap does he time for
a second clue
will he spot that this michelin star has
to be made right under his nose
just
look at this man look never made pasta
before
even after all that he hasn't clicked
come on aldo
two hours in and the course moves on to
zilli's favorite fish we've got and
prepare our own plates of fish for
cooking
let's see what he makes of this
surely he'll smell something fishy when
i finish before most of the others have
even begun have you ever done before
this
is
thank you he's never done it before so
there's no excuse
sir aldo's missed the clue yet again or
has he you know what you remind me of
golden ramsay
doesn't remind you
looks like his dad
are you sure he hasn't sent me his dad
ah i'm about to get rumbled
time to come clean
mr willis with a little bit of flour mr
willie
gordon ramsay would season them
go the ramen will season them i'll see i
season after after cooking because i
don't like salt
i can't eat too much salt
and good
gun ramsay is a [ __ ] nightmare and so
are you
do not you know you know i've known you
since you were standing there right
take your two hours i came today to
learn something and you've learned
nothing i've learned [ __ ] all you
hang on hang on keep it on you look much
better